all right so
hello everybody
this is a very strange backdrop for
those who don't know i am in florida
and uh
and i am doing a seminar on exodus with
jordan peterson so i don't know if you
guys
i think i posted it i posted a picture
of jordan and i on a jet ski which which
seemed to have caused some some
reactions so we're a bunch of people
here and we're doing this seminar on uh
on exodus which is actually why i'm
doing it this in the morning because
jordan has been keeping us pretty busy
and so there was actually an event last
night at his house and some pretty
intense discussions it was good stuff
but uh i decided to change the date and
time for this morning
um
and so all right so as you people know i
as people know you know uh
patrons ask these questions in advance
and uh recently i've been doing it
patron only the q a but i decided to
make it public this morning
just because it's a strange time and i
thought no one's going to show up so i
might as well make it public um
all right so before we start i do have a
few announcements to make
so for those who don't know there's
going to be an event in september
september starting september 15th
uh it's the consciousness and conscious
seminar with with john viveki and uh
and uh and myself and also paul vander
clay so it's gonna be a great a really
great event several days and it's in
thunder bay ontario
there's gonna be it's just gonna be a
lot of time to talk and to discuss we're
gonna do a barbecue and an airsoft and
it's going to be a lot of hangout time
as well getting to know each other i
never met paul vanclain person so i'm
really looking forward to that
and kind of on the same front
there's also in
europe a
something called the bridges of meaning
festival
and so wait i need to find what's going
to be the date
i can't find the date but so the bridge
of meaning festival is going to be is is
paul vander clay and burn power and uh a
bunch of people
i think two more v's is going to be
there i'm not sure sorry if i if i if i
make a mistake it is
anyway so it's all it's in august late
august
and so anyways check it out there's
gonna be a link in the description look
at for the european bridges of meaning
festival
yeah a lot of fun stuff on the horizon
all right so i'm gonna start
looking
all right i mean oh man someone's at my
hotel let me just forget
let me just give a second
what do you want croissant
what
all right all right all right look
jonathan's live okay everybody i've got
him distracted
um he's eating a croissant right now
that's how he pronounced it and when
he's done with that he's gonna have some
poutine so uh finally you're gonna get
some real answers today so
congratulations
i'm appearing as jonathan pajan
my alter ego is here and i'm ready to
answer patreon questions welcome
everyone uh oh i can read the chat this
is exciting hello thank you for knowing
my name
someone um okay so we have a uh we're
gonna start off with some questions from
the website oh isn't there an intro
there needs to be like intro music like
uh this is uh hello i'm jonathan pajan
and this is the symbolic world
that's jurassic park that's a problem
all right okay from first from the
website eric slander says i didn't
pronounce that right and on purpose
hi jonathan or jonathan i hope all is
well with you and that you are blessed
in your undertakings well this guy is
very polite revelations 12 5 uh-oh we're
already off to a bad start here uh she
bore a male child who was to rule all
nations with a rod of iron iron is
multiple hard and brittle as you stated
in one of my previous questions yeah but
it's also not
okay how come christ will come to rule
with rod of this kind of material ps
will you be one of the people taking on
exodus with jordan peterson on the daily
wire
well
i will not but jonathan will and so
that's probably why you're not going to
want to watch it because it's going to
be him and not me all right so the
question really is and it's not even a
good starter question um i'd rather talk
about my new diet i'm on so uh now i'm
down here in miami i realized that i
could like trump the carnivore diet and
that you can actually absorb all the
nutrition you need just from staring at
complex patterns on men's shirts down
here
so that's pretty much all eric needed to
know oh
jonathan's uh jonathan's done eating oh
i better get out of here
um no i was just uh talking to you you
were helping me out there yeah yeah yeah
thank you yeah you can skip question one
i already got all right okay all right
all right so neil has been we've been
hanging out it's been great and so we
thought we would surprise everybody a
little bit all right so i will answer
eric's question
um and so she borrowed me a child so why
is it that it says that christ will
reign with a rod of iron and so the way
to understand the rod of iron
in general is to understand it as an
increasing in power and so
if you look at if you look at the manner
in which the statue of nebuchadnezzar
appears right in the vision of daniel
you have the head of gold then you have
the the i forget like the net body of
silver the arms of brass
uh and you have the legs of iron and so
it
really is understand that we're going
towards the end the end of the world
basically and so we're moving towards
the end and so the the power
the authority is transforming itself
more and more into power and so that's
the reason why
you will see that it is said he will
rule with a rod of iron
so as you can see
neil didn't didn't know how to answer
this question um i actually just gave
people a question they're more
interested in exactly
yes because we know neil is very good
with the complex pattern shirts although
well today well there's there's some
complexity here there's a story to this
this is uh you know like an adult
version of winnie the pooh yeah but yeah
it depends how you mean adult but yes
yes like grown up
there we go all right that sounds better
okay
all right and so all right i will
continue so benjamin rva asks
it is is it significant that the ninth
commandment is to not bear fault with
witness against our neighbor rather than
a broader command not to lie is there a
distinction being made here between
testimony and propositions yes i
definitely do believe that
you know i think you could say something
like yeah it would be good if we didn't
lie
but i think the real moral question is
more about our intention and so i think
the idea of talking about
false witness rather than just the idea
of of not using factuality is much
better and it's actually much closer i
believe to the to the christian
tradition because if you look at some of
the hesi as the the church fathers
especially the desert fathers and the
monastic fathers you will see that they
will sometimes not use they will
sometimes actually use things that are
not factual in order to bring about a
higher truth and and a and deeper
intention so i'm not saying that you
should you you should
lie but it really is about intention and
about communion rather than something
which is just about you know whether or
not something is factual
all right does that make sense to you uh
well nothing makes sense you say but i
just like to be associated with you
um hey cormac jones is that who's next
yeah i just talked to cormac uh we
talked last week
um super interesting guy what how well
do you know him i think we've talked a
few times or once or twice yeah well
he's been writing some screenplays and
he he made an interesting distinction
between like the style of story he was
trying to write and he called what we
were doing homesteading which i kind of
liked where it's like kind of meant to
build
in a traditional sense like a
traditional story the way it builds out
and he deals with these stories i guess
that are like more fringe oriented
it's pretty interesting um anyway uh
smart guy uh i love his uh stuff he's
written for the symbolic world yeah he's
done
with that you should check that out if
you haven't you're all patrons right now
so you probably have this i made this
public this morning so
oh you did hey follow dirt poor robin's
my band
subscribe and like i'm almost at 10 000.
all right all right
okay so here we go so to your mind just
shameless totally so i'll go for it to
your mind what is an iconographer doing
when he or she depicts a demon on an
icon this could be in horrific form as
on the icon of the ladder of divine
descent or in disguise as an old man
tempting joseph in the nativity icon in
either case it seems to be an invocation
of a demon giving it a body expression
but apparently this can be done without
evil purpose would it be possible
alternately for a christian filmmaker to
invoke a demon giving it a cinematic
body of expression and and have this not
uh be to evil purpose so cormac you've
gotta your question is very good and i
would have to say that is it's a
question that is not
does not lack uh controv controversy
there's a lot of controversy within the
world of iconography of
if and how we can or should represent
demons
and there are really different schools
of that so if you look at eastern it's
one of the differences you could say
between western art and eastern
iconography is that
eastern iconography is far more
liturgical and so it's used in the
church a lot more than the manner in
which images were used in the west and
so what it does is that it makes let's i
think it makes the the
imagery more succinct like more
concentrated and the meaning is actually
very very concentrated in eastern
iconography in western iconography
there's more variation and so sometimes
you can understand the meaning by seeing
more variation
and so you have to ask that question so
some iconographers will not represent
demons and icons because you're supposed
to then especially an icon you're going
to venerate and so it makes it more
complicated if you're venerating an icon
and then there's a demon there honestly
i do not subscribe to that because if
you were going to go down that line that
you represent in icons only things that
should be venerated then
then you you will come to very very
ridiculous
levels where there are many things like
you said exactly in your message that
you won't represent joseph being tempted
by the old man because you know that
secretly the old man is the devil you
won't they're meant you like are you
going to represent the soldiers next to
the cross like you're not never going to
represent you're not going to represent
judas in the icons or in the icon of the
last supper for example and so i think
that we have to be a little and so the
manner in which people that do represent
demons in eastern icons they tend to
represent them as completely black in
the sense of lacking light and so this
is a way in which maybe you can play a
little bit with the manner the witch
icon represents themselves in light if
you look at those icons of the ladder of
divine ascent i the the demons in those
icons are usually represented as just as
as black shadows
and so that's different than in western
art where they're represented more as
chimera as monsters but i really like
that representation to help us
understand so i think it could be
possible in a in a movie to to represent
a demon but you're right you would in
some ways be invoking
the demon not in a not in a weird
magical way but that you are definitely
bringing it on screen and so you make
you have to make sure that you're not
doing it
in a gratuitous manner well in the same
way honestly that you also would not
have jesus in a movie because you would
you wouldn't want you have to be very
careful to not do it in a gratuitous
manner so you just have to be
careful and think about it and maybe ask
other people's advice when you're when
you're writing it so what's your take on
the consistency of uh demonic possession
in movies it seems like every director
for the last well since the exorcist
certainly um has displayed it the same
sort of way there's something in the
body that doesn't belong there that it's
it can't behave um
consistently there's always this
sporadic kind of you know outbursts and
pulling it of information uh almost
almost randomly uh what do you make of
that because there seems to be a real
agreement about that depiction of what
possession looks like in film yeah i
think i mean i think it's fine that i i
don't i don't i think the idea of
showing possession is to show exactly
the idea that there's something ruling
the body that shouldn't be ruling the
body and that is making the body do
things that it shouldn't obviously in
movies it will always be exaggerated and
but there's a manner in which i think
that's also okay because movies are not
reality movies are stories and so just
like in the stories sometimes the demons
will have physical form like they will
actually be you know you read these
crazy stories about you know uh
uh
saint margaret you know being eaten by a
dragon and then escaping the dragon by
piercing the dragon out and everything
so you have these very very embodied
stories um and and so i think that if we
understand that movies are not just they
actually aren't just a
you know a depiction of of raw reality
but really our story that condensed
things i think it's okay to to use even
sometimes to have like yeah you could
have you could even have like a physical
demon that you see
uh looking like a gargoyle or something
like that and i think that that could be
fine
uh if it's done properly and and that if
the symbolism makes sense like if you
make if you make it if you it's when you
make it upside down and you would make a
demon
be the good guy or something like that
like they would that they would probably
do today then then that's when you have
a problem
all right
all right so c streetsville asks in
universal history would nazi german and
the holocaust be related to the pattern
of assyria
specifically when assyria was used by
god to judge the nations and to destroy
israel and judah followed by assyria
being judged for its own wickedness both
resulted in a remnant of the jews
returning to rebuild
and resettle israel
and so i would have to say that that is
a it's a very controversial question
it's a very controversial thing
uh there are actually some jews in the
orthodox and in the hasidic camp
that that believe that that believe that
that's one of the reasons why we use the
word holocaust the word holocaust is a
word which refers to a sacrifice and so
there are some jews who believe that the
holocaust
uh was like a kind of sacrifice that led
to the founding of israel
and there are there are others who are
more careful and do not like that that
association so for example we are here
now doing this exodus seminar dennis
prager is here and someone mentioned
that because we talked about the uh the
sacrifice of the the israelite children
before they were before the israelites
were able to leave egypt someone asked
about that in the relationship to the
holocaust and the founding of israel and
he had a very negative reaction he said
he doesn't he he doesn't like that
interpretation
uh so there there are really two schools
on that question
all right so wedge young man says hello
jonathan so no more jokes huh not about
that question well gee come on give me
give me a softball here that's right
hello jonathan i have a question but
wanted to thank you first my father died
a couple of weeks well oh
lord have mercy uh
i know i wouldn't have handled it as
well as i did if it wasn't for the
enlightening and encouraging vision
that you and jordan peterson have shared
my faith is stronger than it's ever been
thank you for playing a part in that
well thanks that's that's very nice
that's very nice
my question is regarding luke 17 when
jesus is talking about the days of the
son of man after jesus finishes
describing the days of the son of man
the apo the apostle
asked him where lord
jesus responds wherever the body is
where the eagles
they're the eagles will be gathered
together
i don't fully understand this would you
share your thoughts thank you for your
help
where the body is there the eagles will
be gathered together
i don't think i've ever even remembered
i remember i haven't read the eagles in
that verse like this is a different
translation that i read i wonder what
else it gets translated as yeah what's
the verse it's luke 17 which was it was
it which is the chapter yeah yeah
i'm gonna look it up look it up yeah
yeah yeah look it up you'll get checked
hold on uh patricics is here um
uh the channel um the two brothers oh
yeah yeah yeah we should give them a
shout out their their channel is great
so yeah
i've just given everybody a hug you're
just you're just wonderful so check out
check out patricic's uh two two uh
uh
two filmmakers from they're from new
zealand right
well i don't think originally from new
zealand because i live in new zealand
yeah deal real short answer so like my
description i've sent this channel to a
bunch of people there's something about
it where it's like uh they're like
simple like really well researched
answers like great um great content to
the uh actual
uh what's the word for it the copy like
the script and but then there's like
there's like 10 percent of like ron
burgundy from anchorman in there
because he's got his tea and he's got
his set and he's got his mahogany chair
and i love it it's just got a great vibe
um so you should definitely check it out
uh every video produced so far i really
like the one recently did on the side of
the cross okay i thought that was
touching go check it out okay i'm still
trying to find uh you know
this so let's give me a chat question so
so alum asked what do you think about
jesus being represented in movies i've
always felt uneasy about it because i
fear about attributing certain fictional
characters to christ i think that i
think that it i honestly i don't believe
that it's impossible
but i do think that we should approach
that with much trepidation and we should
be you know if someone was going to put
christ in a movie they should do so with
fear and trembling and and be really
worried because i think like you i have
been very disappointed
let's just say
in recent representations of of christ
on screen
uh because you can see it's almost as if
it becomes like a mirror of the people
who put who will put him on screen and
so people will put christ on screen in a
way and you can just recognize them it's
like this is your theology this is your
vision of the church this is your vision
of everything and now you're
concentrating that into your figure of
christ and so it is i think
i think in some ways just like christ
does in general if you were gonna
have a fictional version of christ it
can really act as a judge on you you
know it can really kind of manifest
itself as being a judge on you so all
right so so please yeah okay so it's in
the context of the uh you know
two women will be grinding together the
one will be taken the other one left two
men will be in the field one will be
taking the other one left and then he
answered and said to him where lord
so uh then he said to them wherever the
body is there
the eagles will be gathered together
that's very interesting i don't think
i'd ever even thought about that it
thinks i think of a vulture image right
away like but that's not the eagle isn't
the same type of carrion eater no so
it's not so but it does seem reference
to that but it might be a reference to
that and it might also in a certain
manner be a reference
because the the the rapture
uh raptor or you know and rapture or
whatever like the idea of wrath of a ra
of the idea of a rapturous bird is often
an image of heaven but it's used it's
often very often an image a negative
image of heaven which is like heaven
comes down and takes you know you have
this idea when when samuel is is warning
israel about not having a king because
he's saying if you have something above
you it's going to act like like a raptor
and it's going to come and take you from
from the world so i think that this
might be what it's suggesting it's like
you know if where the body of the church
is then that you know the idea that god
will come and take
uh take his you know
in a positive way though this time
well i mean it makes sense because
christ used images like that that might
seem negative but that are positive for
example when he talks about saint peter
becoming a fisher of men you think okay
when you fish you bring it up to eat
right just like the bird comes down and
takes in order to eat but in that in
that question it's like we become food
for god in the positive sense
um
yeah so i think that that's probably
what's going on well you do it that way
i just jump in mouth first
and i don't like people to watch me
eating so it's yeah you eat it down
there in the water
so yes between the the question in the
you know about the the whether those
that brought the water up or there was
water like a dog right oh yeah
like a dog of course of course yeah i
get to be part of gideon's army all
right all right
yeah exactly
all right someone is asking who is the
other guy which it's it's what do you
say john jonathan
if you don't follow my symbolic world
channel
you should definitely no it's wrong
answers only so those that are just
showing up this is neil degrade neil
degrade has a band called dirtball
robins and he just put out a wonderful
series of of of clips on youtube which
were like this beautiful fairy tale
called queen of the night and you also
have to definitely check that out uh
neil and i
collaborate quite a bit you know just in
our discussions and he has a is a very
powerful symbolic intuition although
he's he is a little bit of a clown
though that's not true
so so okay so ramau asked hi jonathan
you said recently that you have been
reading the book meditations of the
tarot by tomberg what are your
impressions of it so far
also if you're if you've already read up
the fourth letter the emperor what do
you think about his idea about
authority uh
freedom and the king crucified god and
so i am reading it but i am reading it
very slowly and so on for now i do
appreciate it there are some things that
are strange about the book like his
reference to
for example uh reincarnation and uh as
people have told me that later he really
refers to taya de chardin which not a
big fan of taya but i would say that his
world view in general and the way that
he describes vertical causality
is very close to what i talk about in
front of the symbolic world and he also
is adding some interesting language
that i think that can maybe that i'll
probably be using because it can help
modern people understand the manner in
which magic happens magic not in a weird
way but just the notion that there are
some causalities which are not just that
the mechanic well not there are
one of the most powerful type of
causality is the one which comes from
from above and and moves down below so
so no i have been enjoying it and i'm
and when i get back home i'm looking
forward to continuing my reading
all right so eagle eagles wing says hi
jonathan what is the symbolism of human
flight
there's a reason developed technology
and so follows a pattern of garments of
skin out of prideful and dangerous
overreaching by humanity to some degree
but it strikes me that this symbol might
be particularly significant since the
human desire for to fly so ancient as to
be almost mythical in and of itself
reference
some of the psalms daedalus and icarus
and ancient cave paintings as a
professional pilot myself who's
passionate about flying i'm also curious
to know how such lofty desires might be
redeemed and not fall into the naturally
prideful tendency since it originated as
a kind of tower of babel trying to reach
the heavens becoming like birds which
are of heaven how can it be rightly
ordered for
man to fly so i think the first thing we
need to
to be able to do so one of the things
that that's happened
in the past few centuries is that
there's been something
of a materialization it's maybe the best
way to understand it where it is that
because we've moved away from our simple
perception of phenomena and we've kind
of moved into technical
perception and also technical use in
order to engage with certain phenomena
then what that leads to is a kind of
materialization it's it's hard to
explain it don't think of it
scientifically but it led to
materialization because we're engaging
with the heavens materially and we're
engaging with certain types of patterns
materially where in the past we weren't
uh and and the same with light the same
with all these things and so because
there's a kind of materialization
the heavens or the heavens that you fly
in in a plane are just not the heavens
that are described in the bible they're
just not the same heavens right the the
outer space
is more akin to like the ocean that a
mariner would go on and encounter
monsters in
than it is related to this the spheres
of heaven that is talked about by dante
so we first of all have to be careful
not to confuse those and it's not it's
not arbitrary it's it's actually
it's meaningful that it is in engaging
with these aspects of reality
mechanically and through the garments of
skin that they materialize themselves
uh and so there's no problem like
there's nothing wrong with the garments
of skin like i've said many times and
there's nothing wrong with flying in an
airplane it is it can become wrong if
like that russian astronaut you you go
up into outer space and then you think
that you've disproved god because
there's no like god for
putting above it's right that becomes
absolutely no spaghetti or monster
that's right that's right so that's when
it becomes ridiculous but i think
properly understanding it in its place i
think that there's no problem in in
flying well i'd add in a non-comedic
sense too that there is um you know all
technologies is an extension of what
people already do just you know
sometimes an exaggeration of it in the
sense that we do already travel we can
travel within our own bodies and so
thinking of the aircraft itself as an
extension like a steed like something
that expands your ability to do that to
let's just say jump really far i think
that's something that's becoming harder
and harder to see that technology is all
based on human activity and and also um
growing one of our own strengths yeah no
you're right and but there is like i i
have to say though
maybe this could be like a little
a different take on it i think that
i think that for someone
who is spiritually attuned
i think that going up in an airplane and
seeing the world from so high above and
seeing the patterns of reality from from
that high i think that that could be
a a very powerful moment if it was
approached with the right heart i i do
believe that though
so um so there's that as well
bette midler agrees that song from a
distance
okay i won't do that all right copyright
infringement that's right on youtube if
you sing you'll be reviewing the reflect
because you you do the imitation so well
like it's just i thought i did i don't
didn't want people to know i had a bette
midler
impersonation no i didn't need to let
that out all right so a popper says what
determines a value hierarchy and why
your different value hierarchies exist
and so value hierarchy is something
which lays itself out based on a an aim
right a purpose and so that that purpose
can be multiple right it can be
everything from a virtue you know that
that you aim at and so you can see the
different levels of attainment of that
virtue but it could also be something
like you know whoever makes the best
pizza would also be something like a
value hierarchy and so it really is only
the hierarchy manifests itself only
because we perceive something
that
is worth uh or worth attaining that is
worth aiming for and hierarchies will
naturally manifest themselves out of
that
and so
and so that's just how it exists and you
can understand that you can understand
it like all these value hierarchies
scale into each other
they're they're they like fractally
exist in each other and they're
ultimately held together by what we
could call the good in the platonic
sense but really they are held together
by the source of all things which is the
god of love and the divine logos which
which manifest
into which all reality is folded and so
what's important to understand is that
there's a manner in which just like in
the natural world
there are these like you could see it
like these all these hierarchies that
you notice in the natural world on these
phenomena they have a form but there's a
there's also a kind of dance to it right
you you can't have an absolutely rigid
system you could have a rigid system
where you have all the value hierarchies
all in a in a pyramid it's more like a
it's something that is that does have a
structure but is also cascading and
there's a there's a kind of dance which
happens so uh and so so if you try to
lay it out and lay everything out you're
going to run into trouble um yeah
i kind of love people that are like just
anti-hierarchy in general but don't
really understand what they're saying
because
to
knock down a hierarchy and describe why
hierarchy is bad you have to have a
hierarchical structure
so i just i don't know i i think that's
one of the funny things about the way
that words seem now too
you know for people who don't understand
this place all right so i have to say
that brad and lisa are in the chat and
i'm very grateful that you have showed
up because they have been going through
really a lot of difficult times so i i'm
very grateful that you guys are showing
up despite everything you're going
through guys so thank you so much thanks
so much
i think bradley came just to make fun of
me
so he couldn't miss the opportunity but
you you're you have a voice he's in
science you should make fun of him right
now oh wow i really could i really could
do something you don't want to incur the
wrath of brad though
here's the hammer he's the hammer i'm
gonna be the bigger man here and just
say you know get well soon bradley yeah
he's thick yeah no he is oh okay get
well soon yeah he got her he just he
just he got a herniated disc and now he
has to like he's in trouble
in south africa so anyways all right
sorry i shouldn't be revealing personal
details but uh but uh but we love them
and we love you guys lisa and brad we
love you guys all right so here we go so
geowad asked hi jonathan as in one of
your videos you had briefly mentioned
that leviathan is a sea monster after
reading job i saw many connections to
him in christ the fish symbolism of
course the fire from the mouth and the
tongues of flame through the holy spirit
he is regarded as a king and the power
of god the etymology of the name
levi hebrew name for united joined
levites priestly cast with no land and
athen greek
for eternal life
is that really the i'm not sure anyways
there are many more connections
personally cosmically that i see but the
question is in spite of its negative
connotations is leviathan a wise
decision for a boy's name in an inverted
world or is this symbol symbolizing of
sea monster scandalous in the orthodox
faith i would avoid
naming your son
leviathan i think that would be a good
idea i think it's important to
understand that the leviathan plays
multiple roles in scripture and you have
to really understand the leviathan as
being the bottom of the world so
you know really is this kind of serpent
at the bottom of the world or the
serpent that is around reality and so
being that
the leviathan
is on the one hand a perfect image of
of the the opposer of the devil of satan
uh but there are places in scripture
where that is not the case where the
leviathan is actually represented as you
know god's pet basically you know
because god there is no total duality in
god you know that there is no complete
duality in god you know all things exist
in the proper place but the leviathan is
of course the best image for the
opposition of the world really in an
ancient mythological
sense of like tiamat this like dragon of
chaos which which tends to oppose god
and so but
as for your perception of the
relationship between the leviathan and
christ i think you're actually on to
something to a certain extent and it has
to do with the fact that in christ's
incarnation he went to the bottom of the
world and that's why he's represented as
the serpent for example as the serpent
uh the bronze serpent or even on the
cross he's represented as a serpent but
we have to be careful not to to confuse
let's say christ who fills the entire
hierarchy and also manifests aspects of
the of of death and of the bottom of the
world and just that symbolism as
something to to kind of revel in and so
you you'd probably be best not to revel
in
leviathan or snake symbolism on its own
but only as it pertains
to its relationship to christ if that
makes sense
all right so choose agape says what can
we learn about love from the story of
abelard and eloise
wouldn't they have
would they have had a happy ending today
if so why
i mean
i think from the story of abelard and
eloise you can learn you could learn the
story i mean that story has a lot to do
with
with pride and a lot to i think it is in
a certain manner
some of the first stories in the
christian tradition in the west where we
do see
someone who
let's say who gives themselves to their
passion out of pride especially avilard
because he was so he was so prideful uh
and then you know i'm not saying that
this consequences that they suffer heard
that abelard was castrated like i'm not
saying that the consequence that they
castrated with a hammer yeah yeah good
stuff
so i'm not
i'm not saying
i'm not saying that avalard deserved
what he got you know i don't want to say
that but i do believe that it is in some
ways an image of and you're right that
if that story
was written today would probably end
well but it's rather for us it should
rather be an image of a story of someone
who
who thinks that they're above reality
and that their actions have no
consequences and uh
yeah so did you know that uh kate and i
met in a musical about abellard i was
cast as abelard and she was cast as
eloise my wife and i met that way yeah
um what's your take on it then uh the
story well i thought so you know
shakespeare also allegedly based romeo
and juliet on this story
and that's a tragedy as well yeah so uh
i think that shakespeare at least saw
something about the pattern where you
know it that it matched the complexity
of life and sort of the inevitability of
these kind of actions so someone who
whose job was to stay pure you know as a
12th century philosopher and theologian
he was supposed to stay pure and
undefiled you know was trying to have
this this sort of pride about what he
was teaching at the same time take this
thing on the side that was forbidden so
i think that's how it if you're writing
a tragedy that's how the story ends
sadly i mean also you have to consider
in uh you know if this hap took place in
2022 i think that abelard um he would
just be the name of like some kind of
new synthetic fat substitute
so that's pretty much it that's all you
needed to know on the subject okay
abillard
on your chips it's delicious okay
all right and so
all right and so we are moving to the
patreon questions so for those who are
just dropping in uh you know i i get
questions from my supporters from
the website and also from patreon so we
are going to patreon all right so norn
norn iron man ask my wife and i have
been trying to have children for many
years and have suffered two miscarriages
the most recent of which was a few years
ago now my wife turned 40 recently and i
turned 41 but i kept telling her not to
give up hope i always think of the story
of abraham and sarah when i'm trying to
reassure her but i've recently been
wondering what is the deeper symbolism
behind
the story
in it abraham basically has given up
hope so is it wrong for me to think of
it as a way of reassuring myself i
understand it may never happen but what
is god trying to show us about how we
should feel in this situation
so i think that
i think we it's one of those things
where
we have to be on the one hand i agree
that we we should look at scripture and
kind of find hope in scripture but we
should also be careful not to see that
scripture is there to
help us
how can i say this that historian
scripture is there as a kind of
map of our own experience exactly
because so
it's very important to understand that
in the story of abraham
the reason why abraham is losing hope
and should not lose hope is that god
told him that he would have a son
clearly and so that's also part of the
story it's as if god told abraham he
would have a son and then
his the possibility wasn't manifesting
itself to a point where he you know in a
manner in which that you could say there
was no way that this could be something
that came only from abraham and sarah
and so it was stretched to a limit where
abraham was so old and sarah was so old
that the birth of their son
appeared as providential and so carried
with it that kind of providential sense
and so you could say that for example in
your case as well
that long desire it's not exactly the
same but let's say that desire to have a
child for such a long time and to be
patient and to keep your heart you know
if if god grants you that wish then in a
certain manner that child will be more
precious to you than to someone you know
who's who just gets married at 19 and
gets pregnant right away
just in terms of experience and so so i
think that
so i think that i don't think that you
necessarily have to give up hope of
course
it is possible that that is not what god
god wants for you and that you will not
have a child but but if you do then
maybe you can see how
how this longing that you've had this
like this longing for many many years
you know will also put
weight and value in in in the miracle if
it happens so so we pray that it that it
does for you
all right so matthew o'hare says
what's your understanding of why christ
had to return to the father
for the holy spirit to come
um
so
the way that the way that i understand
this
has something to do and this is
something that i'm going to be if this
is going to sound this could be very
speculative because it's actually
something i've been thinking about a
while and i i've been kind of playing
with with with it and i don't totally
understand it but it has to do with the
pattern of the ascent
before
the beginning of a new world
and so
you see that before the flood enoch gets
taken up
you know there's also the destruction of
the world so it's like the end of a
world in the beginning of a world and so
enoch gets taken up taken up and then
there's a flood and then there's a new
beginning
elijah gets taken up and you know and
it's the end of the kingdom of israel
and then there's a new beginning with
judah
and then ultimately
christ gets taken up
jerusalem itself is destroyed but it's
also the beginning of of the church and
of this universal church so there seems
to be something about how
in order for something new to happen
the head
right the logos has to be
kind of taken up into heaven is the only
way to say it and that that does is that
makes things
on the one hand collapse because
everything that was held by that head
somehow and then everything collapses
but that also leads to
the new spirit right because when when
we say the holy spirit comes down you
have to remember that it that's what
happened at the beginning of creation
right the spirit of god which comes down
on the water
that is how the world comes to exist the
spirit of god which blows you know uh
through the red sea and opens it up to
reveal the new earth that is that is how
it happens right the spirit of god would
descend on christ as he comes out of the
water to to to be revealed publicly as
the son of god so this is the holy
spirit coming down isn't just like an
arbitrary thing it's something which
reveals dry land right and so in in
scripture it
in
in in the new testament it's even wilder
because it's not just dry land it's like
a fire that burns you know and kind of
fills the world with its with its drying
capacity you know like revealing
revealing the body in its fullness so i
think that
that it has something to do with that it
has something to do with how christ has
to leave the world
to kind of fill the world with god's
presence completely yeah that's that uh
the short parable about unless a grain
of wheat dies and falls it remains alone
but if it dies it produces this harvest
and so
it's about it christ
explains that so there's a larger
participation in him that follows
through the spirit
all right
how about this you know if you if you're
able like
try to kind of try to participate a
little bit in the chat not participate
but like see if they're yeah if anybody
says anything intelligent in the chat it
really happened never right no no
bradley will uh will block them you'll
block them with this system if they say
something good
so
what's this with 28 degrees celsius who
uses celsius what is i'm a canadian man
all right so
all right so matthew o'hare sorry let me
just make sure
oh wait is this like french for like
accept or ban i'm gonna block because
that's somewhere
don't comment on those being black no
they don't they don't deserve our
attention all right got it all right so
sorry sir ajafka asked what is the
difference between a healthy religion
and a sect cult
wow that's a weird question i mean
religion is based on
religions are based on true revelations
right they're not just
someone who
and they also are never something new
they're never something self-declared so
listen actually this is if you wanted to
think to look at it
uh
even in terms of christianity
so
a prophet let's not even talk about a
religion let's say
prophets and religious authorities are
never self-declared so if you want to
know if something is a sect or cult the
first thing you can see is where does
that guy come from who told us that this
person had authority are they just
self-declared as being
revealers or whatever you know whereas
like even the story of christ
the the christ goes to his own cousin
saint john the foreigner
and then he asked saint john to baptize
him and saint john's like why am i
baptizing you you should be baptizing me
and christ says it has to happen this
way
he even though christ had the ultimate
authority in the way that the story laid
itself out he had to receive
his authority from above and that there
had to be like a public vision of that
but it also had to come through this
prophetic line of prophets where it was
almost like saint john was also
initiating him or kind of acting as
someone who is pointing to him and
saying this is the one right this is the
lamb of god who takes away the sin of
the world and so
and so
that's why you you can understand that
also when when christ came into the
world he didn't just start a new
religion that's nonsense jesus did not
start a new religion he came as a
revelation of the of the of the
manifestation of god which happened
you know in the time of as the god of
abraham isaac and jacob but also as the
god of noah and as the god of adam and
so it's it's a it's a it's a
continuation not a not a new thing so
most of the sex sex and cults you will
see are like self-declared pastors or
self-declared gurus or you know self
declared this and they're you know
that's that's a good sign right away to
know if something is total nonsense
yeah i think the the short of it too
like every friend i've ever known that's
been in the cult there's always a leader
just a real basic way to look at it too
there's always seems to be a leader
who's trying to supplant your
decision-making power with their own you
know they're trying to they're not
trying to
build you up to go out in the world and
make better decisions there's this kind
of micromanagement kind of
approach too now uh jonathan henry he
was asking i think he's about asking
about your heavenly mountain uh picture
here um
can we can be understood like fractally
as each soul uh covered with fig leaves
outwardly reliant until baptism when the
living water christ returns i've always
been fascinated with this image but this
but the the whole idea here is that the
image does work practically
practically on every level yes yes it's
so so the image of everything can be
seen as an image of a person it can be
it can be understand of course it's not
but it can be applied to a person
where
we're you know where the highest aspect
of you is something like christ in you
that is the highest aspect of you the
aspect of you where you actually touch
the infinite where it's in some manners
not you anymore but it is none the less
than you and then you have the different
faculties of of the person the different
faculties of the soul leading also to
the garments of skin into the place in
which we
you know fall apart into
into nothingness so so it is definitely
an image of of a person
all right so
no norm goldeneye says the question
about the book of tobit
what's this about significance of tobias
getting the liver heart and gall from a
fish using the liver and heart to cast
out sarah's demon using the gall to
remove the film from tobit's eyes did
the fish connect to the coin peter finds
in the fish
or the gall to psalm 69 that was given
to the suffering man
and so
this is this really is
in my vision it's something it is like
an apple tropic practice
and so it's really taking something
of fish like this and also taking
something of death and using it to cast
out uh death like to cast out a demon so
you could think about like taking the
gall of a fish
you know and to remove the film from
tobit's eyes like christ takes
dirt like takes dust on the ground so
that could be like the ultimate version
of that where he takes dust on the
ground and uses it to to heal the blind
man um that is the way that i see it and
so the fish
the fish symbolism is extremely
complicated it's it's very complex
because on the one hand the fish
represent
that which is that below in the water
you can see it that way
and so there's a negative aspect to that
it can also appear as life which is
hidden in the waters
you know like this these shiny things
that are still bright even though
they're deep they're in the deep um
and so so so there's a kind of a double
symbolism about fish and and so and for
example like when saint peter finds the
coin in the fish in that case the fish
becomes just this like kind of dark
potential and then the surprise is the
coin inside but sometimes the fish
itself acts as this surprise like oh
it's all dark and there's this shiny
moving thing in the waters
so yeah so it's a complex symbolism
definitely
all right so abe says what is the
symbolism of saint michael being the
second of the second lowest choir of
angels archangels one would expect an
angel of a higher ranking choir to be
the one to lead god's angels against the
dragon and his angels during the war in
heaven and so i understand your
intuition but i think
you have to understand that
the highest aspect of reality is not
fighting
and also the highest aspect of reality
is not managing the highest aspect of
reality is worship so the highest choirs
of angels their function
is actually not turned towards us
it's turned towards god it is they they
surround the throne of god they worship
they sing you know they act as veils for
the throne of god and so that's why the
highest angels are actually in some
manners not involved
in the things of humans and then as you
come lower then you f you see kind of an
activation
of god's will into the world through
these lower choirs of angels which are
now relating directly to us and so you
could understand that you know the the
maybe you could see it like that the
higher higher choirs of angels are
acting subtly on the angels that we see
as
acting more
explicitly let's say and so the manner
in which for example the higher choirs
of angels would
would be experienced by the
by the archangels you know they might
see them in a kind of maybe more active
role because they're closer and they but
i that's very speculative on my part but
that's why that's why it's because
because contemplation and prayer and
worship is higher than fighting and
managing the world
so there's no chance it's not that they
had too many tenors at the higher choir
already
and michael was it no okay he was more
like a real important question here i'm
noticing i can't skip this one uh you
know jacob it's jacob yeah he says
what's the symbolism of a grown man
wearing jorts he made himself
i don't even wear george shorts or like
you cut jeans into oh
man that's like that's like rebellion i
think it's just rebellious i feel like
you found a picture of me online i think
jacob i think yeah i think you're i
think that when you see that you see
someone's secret deep rebellion in their
hearts
yeah no but i've worn george before
but i'm grown up now so why would i do
that neil
that's a question for jacob because uh i
don't know what's happening no where's
joey don't worry jordan i'm standing up
now all right
all right so alex
cilento said jordan peterson asked
muslim christians and jews to unite over
our book in order to protect what is
sacred what is your take on this idea is
this possible and or practical so for
all my love of jordan i think that no
i i don't think that i don't think that
we are people of the book honestly i do
not think that christians are people of
the book i think where people
think that saying that we are those who
worship the one god it would be better
you know in order to understand what it
is exactly
that binds us because our book doesn't
bind us you know the the reality is that
that that oh i understand you know
islam
supersedes you know acts
you know the way that it sets itself up
is that it supersedes christianity and
it supersedes christianity and judaism
in ways that are very extreme because
although they keep the story they've
changed the very essence of the story so
they they for example so they they say
christ but they say christ was not
crucified
and so they say they say abraham
but then they say you know
it wasn't isaac who was the the
preferred son and the one who was going
to be sacrificed and so in some ways
they keep the story but they really
remove what at least for christians is
the very poor and essence of the story
uh and so i think that nonetheless i i
do think that the fact that christians
jews and muslims
believe in the god of abraham and that
they also
they also do have a monotheistic
direction i think that that might be a
better
place for us to be able
not to unite together in a in a in a
in a direct way but see each other
sometimes
as allies especially in a world where
things are falling apart you know and
there's this like
there there are satanic orders that are
appearing around us uh i think that in
that case it would be very useful to for
christian jews and muslims to work
together
uh to the extent that they can just like
i believe in the same thing in
christianity i think i'm not a fan of of
of simple ecumenism where it's like
we're all just going to get together in
kumbaya i think that we have to
recognize the reality of our differences
and and also understand the man in which
we are joined together to the body in
which we commune but you know i will
ally myself with protestants and
catholics every day of the week in the
places that it is appropriate to do so
and so i think in terms of jews and
muslims i think that is the same and you
could also to be honest you could
actually extend that even
bigger and say there is a manner in
which all traditional religions of the
world could ally themselves in some ways
to fight you know the
ai system of antichrist which is like
kind of looming on us where this kind of
weird secular technocratic world uh so i
think that there could be ways for us to
unite across all kinds of all kinds of
uh different groups let's say
you got more croissants over there yeah
i don't know yeah someone's like what's
going on who's next coming in the room
why are they yelling that's right
all right so
it's gonna beat me up next
[Laughter]
all right so marcus davis says what is
more representative of the logo speaking
or writing i think that's pretty clear
it is speaking
next question
so experience says hi jonathan sorry i'm
being a little simplistic but i think
that it's clear that speaking is closer
to the logos and you have to understand
it so so if you can imagine in your mind
an image of of the icon of christ you
will see that christ has in his red in
his right hand he holds up his hand as a
blessing
which is the speaking in the sense of
the direct influence
and then in his left hand he holds a
book which is something like the
roundabout the indirect but also the
fixed and so logos is something fluid
fluid not in the bad sense but fluid in
the sense that it is direct and it is
you know
it holds the spirit
directly right when you speak you push
the spirit out is the best way to say it
whereas the the book would be something
like inspired by the spirit in the sense
that
the spirit has made it happen but it but
it is fixed and so it's it's more like a
boundary or a or a bulwark against error
okay so maybe that's a good way to
understand the difference between
speech and writing
all right so xperez asks
i hi jonathan i hope this finds you well
and i was wondering if you'd be able to
comment on the significance of embodied
aesthetic practice as they relate to
margin
and historical transition periods thank
you in advance
yes i understand the question i see it's
phrased a little weirdly maybe for
people but i think i understand what you
mean so what you mean is that
there's a man in which as we move
towards when our as we are in transition
periods as we are kind of at the end of
something
moving into the beginning of something
we can notice that even in the manner in
which art is represented whether it be
for us now like movies and music all
this stuff whether it be in the past
where it's going to be sculptures or
whatever that you will see
a kind of uh
of the marginal of the confused you know
for example at the end of the roman
empire there was this obsession with the
hermaphroditic
figure and so you would see
quite a few uh representations of the
hermaphrodite and so you could say well
same thing is happening now it's
actually a sign of the end when you see
the hermaphrodite you know manifested
over and over this confusion of
of of identity just just being becoming
popular so i would say that
the best way to understand it would be
that we need to be able to
have things in their proper place so
it's not wrong to use
ambiguous
symbolism think about the the way in
which i'm using the icon of saint krista
for example it's okay to use ambiguous
symbolism but you have to understand
where its place is and what its role is
so the difficulty that we have now is
that people
let's say worship ambiguity
so people that people have taken
something which is some something like
abominable
and have put it into the altar right
when the abomination is in the highest
place that's when you know like the end
is coming right that's when you know
when it's the end when people have taken
the abomination and put it in the
highest place when someone has put a
gargoyle so gargoyles are fine in a
church but if you see if you go into a
church and there's a gargoyle on the
altar
right you know that we're in trouble
okay uh and so so so that is the best
way to understand it so you have to be
wise and you have to be able to see
to what extent you're acting in passion
and and in just in kind of dark
curiosity or dark desires uh but it is
okay not only okay but i think it's
important for us to recapture ambigu
ambiguous symbolism and let's say the
aesthetic uh symbolism of the margins
well that makes sense yeah it does well
i mean you can see that too just in pop
culture in a movie like shrek
where they occupy all these fairy tale
forms
and he starts out you know with the he
makes sense as an ogre the way he's
behaving and whatnot but then the whole
point is the ogre becomes king but the
ogre stays an ogre right and so you
start to realize that they're just
picking up things from fairy tale world
and using them like costumes
on normal personality and people types
instead of as more of a cosmic image to
represent a pattern to civilization
because if the ogre of season ogre
remains king well that's uh you know you
have the hermit in the center of the
world what like how is he going to look
out for the rest of the people yeah it
wouldn't like it's a bad story at that
point it loses
i mean it is it is it is definitely not
only is it upside down story but if you
watch shrek attentively right at the
beginning they tell you that this is
going to be an upside down story and
that happens in the the outhouse like
you know it right away because when he
goes to the outhouse to do his business
he takes a fairy tale book
a beautiful fairy tale book with like
beautiful images and he rips the pages
out a page out and he uses it to wipe
himself and so that's shrek track it all
the shrek is that image right there and
smash mouth
and the smash mouth yeah
that's just
not a great combo all right oh cause
this song i was like what like
okay oh more copyright infringement yes
years ago i only got eight notes in not
even all right so we should be okay
and you didn't do it so well this time
so well yeah
i didn't want to i didn't want to
shatter your screen
all right so maximus maggiar says hi
brother maximus could you tell us about
a time when something in the orthodox
tradition seemed very symbolically off
and then you discovered it wasn't
oh man there are definitely examples of
that
and okay so this is the best one
so
in the 6th century there is a famous
image of christ
at the last judgment
and and so christ this is at in ravenna
you can look it up and so look at uh the
story uh last sixth century mosaic
of the last judgment mosaic uh last
judgment and so you see christ
sitting and then he has his hands out
and so on his right hand he has the
sheep and on his left hand he has the
goats and then behind him he has a
bright red angel and a bright blue angel
but the red angel
is on his right hand and the blue angel
is on his left hand and that bothered me
for
15 years
like it just bothered me so much i was
like why the red angel should be on
christ's left hand with the goats and
then the the blue angels should be on
christ's right hand with the the the
sheep um
and it's only much more much recently
that i've understood how the left hand
and the right hand cross like this and
how the the the
the cause and the effect are are
actually opposite
um
and uh and so
and so that that i once i've understood
that then i'm like okay so then i could
see for example that the same issue
happened in the icon of the
transfiguration where you you actually
saw a crossing of the left and the right
hand you know from
from the prophetic
to to uh to to saint peter anyway so so
i've been thinking about that a lot so
it doesn't necessarily always have to be
represented like that uh but definitely
it makes sense that it is represented
that way
um so hopefully that makes sense
but it's a symbolism that i still
struggle to communicate clearly that's
why i haven't made like a full video
about it but it it's talking about a
baseball player in the baseball glove
look who's in the chat oh okay it's a
grade who's kate the great i don't know
she's wonderful as far as i know
that's all i know uh kate you missed it
we were talking about abelard and eloise
earlier you would have especially liked
that she's an expert on eloise so
so kate i'm taking good care of neil
like yeah he's not getting into any
trouble at all he's feeding me and stuff
it's really helpful
sending me to bed at a proper hour
all right and so here we go so brandon
asks hi jonathan hope all is well spent
a lot of time thinking and learning
about god but less communing with him in
prayer
that is the that is probably all of our
diseases so mine as well my assumption
is that communion with god is of far
greater importance than thinking and
learning about him yes you are right
however i can't help but think that
hitting the books still has a role to
play what are your thoughts on the
relative importance of these two things
and how they interplay with one another
god bless you and thank you so
the best way to understand it really is
that it's it's much lower on the ring of
importance it's much lower on the ring
the hierarchy of what we should be
attending to um but that like you said
it does have its place and to a certain
manner it can be
proper preparation for our prayer life
although we should be aiming towards
prayer but i i think that all of us
especially that live in a in a secular
world that we that you know we go to
church once a week or twice a week
uh it is it is something that we all
struggle with and we're distracted and i
struggle with the same but i think that
i think that we we we do what you know
we do what we can and with the grace of
god you you it's good that you it's
better that you learn about god and re
reading about that in books then you
learn about other random things or evil
things or whatever it is you're doing
and so
hopefully we're all moving together
towards a a deeper and more profound
prayer life now do we really live in a
secular world or a world that thinks
it's a secular world
i would say to the extent that the
secular world is an extension of the
sacred world if you see it that way that
it is kind of like the outside so the
manner in which like i was reading san
gregor nissa again
just this week and he does talk about
the difference between let's say the
sacred reality of the church and of its
mysteries and the secular world the
pagan learning scientific learning all
these things and he does oppose them and
he sees it as one should simply be
subjugated to the other and so he talks
about for example he uses the image of
moses's wives the fact that moses or
even moses mothers for example is a
great great version of that where he
says moses had two mothers yeah he had a
hebrew mother and an egyptian mother
and that
and that the the egyptian mother is all
of the secular world you know like i
said learning philosophy
et cetera et cetera and that it is
useful but that you know he got his milk
like he got the actual the food he would
get from his true mother and so if we
subordinate let's say the secular world
to the sacred then it actually ends up
being like you said in some ways it
actually just flows from it right it's
not it it actually kind of is just a
another another instantiation on the
latter of the same type of things
yeah but if if yogurt is just milk gone
bad how do we know when yogurt goes bad
it it
it's a hierarchy it's just a higher key
higher okay got it get it that's how we
get out of all these questions hierarchy
um
all right so anders ralstad says hi
jonathan where's the symbolism of having
pictures of the royal family by the
toilet
what this is common practice in norway
typically no cabins i've heard that the
practice started because back in the day
paper for magazines were used to clean
oneself however the pages with the
picture of the royal family were not
used for this but saved and put on
display instead i've never
heard anything of this i never heard any
of this so uh
works for me
yeah so i'm afraid that i cannot answer
do you have an answer do you have an
answer neil it's very odd
yeah but it's not the right one
continue all right so here all right
wesley wesley swank is there
all right oh but he's been blocked
someone's been there there's a lot of
blocking sorry sorry a lot of lucky you
should see behind the scenes the chaos
of youtube
yogurt and milk summon the bots that's
it i'm sorry i mentioned yogurt ah come
on wesley's not about though oh well i
wish he's our friend oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah wesley is a friend all right sorry
so dorothea says what is significance of
the wife of moses rather than moses
himself performing the circumcision of
their son
then she touches his feet with the
foreskin question mark for some reason
it reminded me of the painting of the
virgin standing on the head of a snake
and i guess you could use circumcision
as something like a snake removing its
skin but i don't know
so the way that the way that um thank
gregory that's right it's always i've
got to go back to gregor mesa so the way
this thing gregory nisa
uh describes it is that it has to do
exactly with the foreign wife
and so moses marries a foreign wife and
she is like a companion the way that
secular the secular world is a companion
to us but that that companion
has to purify its fruits you could say
so it it it it's not just okay on its
own and so that's what circumcision is
so you could say that the way that it's
seen is that
in circumcising her son the wife of
moses let's say
purified the fruits of their union and
made it
proper you know and so
removing the garments of skin which is
the mark of the foreigner
is the man in which that happens now the
fact that the foreskin is touched to the
feet of
of moses this is not saint gregor nisa
this is my own intuition i think it has
to do with moses's sandals and it's to
shoot to relate so
sangria nissa relates directly
circumcision with removing the sandals
at
at the at the the burning bush but he
doesn't
talk about that story particularly about
that but i think that's what it is i
think that you know he understands it
completely and he doesn't give you all
the details so i think that the fact
that that uh that her that the wife
that zipporah will touch
moses's feet with the the foreskin is to
help you understand that when moses
removes the sandals it's something like
the circumcision itself and then uh well
also he kind of sums that chapter up or
that little um section up with
something practical because in the life
of moses he's he's really giving this
very practical advice on how to
understand uh these things that happened
in the story of mo uh in the life of
moses but also like a takeaway so his
principle takeaway from that i thought
was so cool was
the idea that you know taking the
foreign wife it's okay to entertain
foreign philosophies and look for the
good in them but as long as no
defilement remains that's right if you
leave the defilement with it you know if
you pick up this practice or like
someone was talking in the chat about
you know other religions that seem to
have some good symbolism and things like
that like all good is god's good in that
sense but at the same time if you if you
leave the foreign
element that defiles the practice then
it's no good no and you and it you
really have to take it
like this is this is extreme so for
example you know the the the fathers or
the the ancient christians they would
read
you know something like metamorphosis by
ovid they would get
you know uh powerful intuitions and
powerful moral intuitions from them but
if you read metamorphosis on its own and
there's scandal after scandal everything
about it is scandalous it's the same
with plato so we can take things from
plato that are that are powerful and
useful
and you can even read the symposium for
example i've talked i mentioned this
before you can read the symposium and
view the manner in which desires
transmuted
into higher goods but it's like yeah but
they're also a bunch of pederast and
like that's not good like we have to be
able to get rid of the aspect of it
which is which is dangerous and and uh
so so so that's what i think that's the
work that's in gregory is calling us to
do as christians in kind of purifying
pagan knowledge towards a better purpose
right
all right
so
do you see something in the uh i'm just
gonna make sure it's okay
um okay uh i mean this is interesting to
me um
mika uh hey guys i'm new to these
questions in a uh q a sessions my
question is the following how to know
when one including myself can uh i think
that's realized being an orthodox
christian
uh what are the marks of being true
orthodox
i mean it that you me if you mean like
external marks like you you have to be
baptized you have to be christmated uh
and then you also have to go to
confession and you have to
you have to commute like that's how
those are like say the external marks
of being orthodox
um you know so there is there is
something which is embodied it's a
practical thing it's not just about what
we think or what we believe um and then
you have to say the creed you have to
to you do have to believe certain things
you don't have to believe everything
that every orthodox believes but you
have to there is a certain
quantity of things and it's not clear
it's organic it's in negotiation with
the with your priest with with your
history with with the hierarchy of
things that you have to adhere to
um but that's how you
that's how you know you know if you're
not if you're not uh
if you're not baptized and you're not
christmated and you don't commune
you're not orthodox in any way not even
like little orthodox right because
because i think that any even the most
protestant denomination
uh like that more the most kind of let's
say
even home church would believe that you
have to be baptized right that in order
to be truly participating in the body i
mean and now well that's true that's one
of the things that's confusing for some
people i think with the reading acts
because there are moments where you find
these pockets of people that have
believed in john's baptism
but uh there's that there's an actual
like hand-to-hand transfer of the church
in body too that the apostles would go
out and then they would you know receive
the holy spirit uh not just the baptism
too so that's that's something when
you're trying to understand orthodoxy
too i think it's hard to understand the
modern world because um we think of
everything as just the propositional
knowledge not the the
where the body resides and how it
results yeah so when you were
christmated when you were baptized and
then your chris made it you get the two
of the of what of what neil's talking
about there's baptism and then there's
reception from above of the holy spirit
yeah that's a longer conversation too
but one of the things i think that is
hard to understand too prior to you know
the last you know 500 years is that most
of the arguments and attempts at schisms
in the church for a long time no one it
seemed like there didn't seem to be any
power to just break off and start
something that lasted for a long time it
was it was almost like you're working at
a police department nowadays and you had
some difference of opinion about like
what the police ought to be doing
um you can talk to your boss about it
you can try to change people's minds but
you can't go and start your own police
department that's right and so you know
you have no authority to start your own
police department so there wasn't a more
embodied way of looking at what the
church was where people were really
arguing over for what this body should
be doing and believing more than they
thought they could be like well if
there's a difference of opinion we have
the right to go over here and just start
our own police department
if you will
alright so blake strait asked if christ
feels the hierarchy and crisis in all
things is communion the gift given to
help us understand this like god is
everything but as regular human it's
impossible to live in this per this
world of perfected love for very long so
communion is our portal towards this we
understand so i think you would you
would i would be careful to to to let's
say formulated as just understanding it
really is knowledge in the deepest sense
of uh you know of a man knowing his wife
it is it is a embodied participation
uh so that that's first thing but in a
certain manner yes so you
i think that the best way to understand
it is that
just like christ is the pinnacle let's
say and is the incarnation of god and
man and that to the extent that we are
in christ we participate
in that reality in the same way
communion within the life of the
christian
is the pinnacle of that of the place
where we encounter god and we receive
god in us
but then that also pours out and flows
out into
everything else and so you have to see
it in terms of of hierarchy
uh
hierarchy that's the answer to
everything i think too in a modern sense
the words do this in remembrance of me
people i think in a modern setting that
word remembrance is means like oh just
you know emblematically or or you know
propositionally that's what's really
important here the explanation of what
we're doing not the act itself or the
sacrament itself yeah and and i
mentioned this before but but memory is
the manner in which we are connected to
something which is distant from us so
it's not a it's not just a it's not just
a theoretical uh connection but it is a
true connection to something which is
which is far away from us and the notion
of pure memory is something like a
paradox where the pure memory that
christ is
that is giving us is something where it
is both distant that is it is bread and
wine but we say it is fully the body and
blood of christ not just a not just a a
sign not just an emblem but it is a true
transformation and especially the
orthodox tradition while it also remains
red and wine so it is a paradox of
course it is but it it also if you if
you you peer into the paradox with the
right eyes and the right disposition
you'll notice that it really is in a way
the ultimate representation of how
reality actually lays itself out you
know in terms of how patterns
you know
multiply themselves and and and this
idea of the memory of the principle
which has given the the pattern that
you're participating in
um
all right so jared widener says hello
jonathan can you comment on the
symbolism of either excessive or
restrictive
drinking of water
hmm
i don't know do you have an insight on
that i don't i don't know i can just
start talking
about it isn't that what you do
you just don't sound like you know what
you're doing that's how you usually do
it how would you start talking well you
guys know the water is it's it's not
actually wet it wettens
that's the first thing we need to
understand about water
all right so we have to stop now okay so
so the uh
i mean i think that i mean i don't know
i've never thought about this like i
mean obviously if you drink too much
water you will feel bloated
and you will turtle flood that you'll
feel an internal flood and if you drink
too little water then you'll be
dehydrated and you'll feel something
like a desert so
your lips will start cracking just like
the ears start cracking you're a little
microcosm
i don't that's what you mean i'm not
sure
or if you mean more like fasting maybe
i'm not sure anyway so that's the best i
can do sorry
um all right so tiered says what is the
symbolism of stress and the resulting
need for distraction
so
i mean it has to do with work and rest i
think that's probably the better way to
to represent it is that you we have work
and that work builds up
you know in us and it also
it uses up our energy and then when we
rest then we refill ourselves like right
we let's say we we replenish ourselves
or revivify ourselves so it's best to
understand it like work and sleep but
also like you said it could be
distraction in the sense of you know
of doing things purposefully and then
playing games or just kind of talking
with friends in a way that also is
refreshing so it's the difference
between purposeful action and then rest
from purposeful action you could say
um
all right so nate barker says hey
jonathan do you have any tips or
guidelines for interpreting stories
symbolically
that next next i have a grasp on the
main
symbols that you met you talked about
having an earth space and time margin
but i often have trouble interpreting
what a story or a part of a scripture is
trying to say on a symbolic level so
can we not the rest of the time for this
one this is a good one it is a very good
one so there's there are a few things so
one is the pattern that mets here for
example sits out in his book
is
is the is the very powerful it's almost
geometric right it's geometric it's
mathematical it is this kind of pure
pattern where if you see the pattern
then you
start to see it manifest itself in the
world but you also need a kind of
experience
so just because you read matthew's book
you probably won't have enough to then
go and
and and interpret everything you you
have to practice
that practice also means filling up the
pattern with information with with
details
so what's what you need to do is is you
need to read a lot of stories you need
to read the bible read the bible read
the stories know the stories like do you
know the stories you know can you if i
ask you can you tell me the sequence of
genesis like what are the different
stories in line and if can you know
after that what happens in exodus and
joshua and the judges like you have
let's say a basic story structure in
your mind of history of the bible and
then
then you also probably need other
stories especially in our world now like
do you know your fairy tale do you know
do you know the you know the stories and
so once
so there is a kind of work that you have
to do that is not just learning the the
pattern
and then when you know the stories and
you have them in your mind especially if
you have them in you then the
connections will start to happen if
you're attentive and you'll start to see
the the
the patterns and you'll start to see
well this is a stand-in for that this is
a stand-in for that in that story
especially within scripture at first
and then slowly the the your your muscle
is going to say your interpretation
muscle is going to start to
to to to manifest itself so that is that
to me honestly is is something that i i
think is important and so you have to be
patient and it takes time and it takes
like anything it takes practice and it
takes attention um and i think slowly
you'll you'll you'll get there so yeah i
love some of the guidelines you've given
in the past about these things too that
like also it should work fractically up
and down right it can be
the element of the story can be
description of an internal process it
can be a description of like a family in
action a city a cosmic pattern
um also looking for
uh things that appear in the story as a
condensed pattern that happens in
reality uh you know for example if
you're watching a story and you see
someone go to a crossroads and they're
going to sell their soul like this is
like a fun trope in movies i like um and
so that pattern happens slower in real
life have you ever known someone who's
who's been going after something at the
sake of everything else you can see that
they'll make these incremental decisions
they won't necessarily sign one document
one time and that's the moment they sold
their soul it's something that happens
over a longer period of time it gets
condensed and then the other side of it
is there's patterns and stories that are
things that happen very quickly in life
that are expanded like the actual
pattern of the story itself
and so if you start to see those things
i think it becomes more helpful to um
interpret yeah that's really good advice
that it's definitely good advice to to
always
when you're looking at a story try to
apply it at different levels of reality
like you'll see it when someone asks a
question or sometimes when i'm
interpreting a text
you'll notice that i'll often give an
example like a personal example a social
example and maybe an analogy with
another story to try to kind of move
across all these different
levels and different instantiations to
verify whether or not my intuition about
the story is right if you so you if you
don't do that that's when you can kind
of be led astray especially with details
people get caught up in details of
stories and start to interpret a symbol
on its own but you always that's another
advice too is you always have to
interpret whatever thing symbol you're
interpreting within the context of the
actual story but then also in analogy
with other stories and other levels of
of reality and so and another thing like
for a more complex story one of the
things
uh that you were pointing to neil is
that you'll often see it within the
story you'll see a fractal relationship
which is that
the elements of the story will manifest
the bigger narrative the bigger
structure of the story uh and so if you
can start to see that then you're
probably on a good
you're probably uh in the looking in the
right direction yeah i think uh tokens
on fairy stories is a good sort of
adjacent work to this idea the way he's
explaining some of the patterns i think
token was very careful not to injure the
story as he breaks it down which i think
is something um you know you can see
that in the in the story of peter pan uh
that when he's been telling these
stories about peter pan their dog nana
drives the shadow off because that's the
grounded one trying to keep everybody
grounded and to go on this journey and
to kind of break because peter pan
especially in the disney movie is a
really clear like discussion of
symbolism and past storytelling in the
modern world so they recognize right
away that there's an injury you have to
do to the story to to make it
participate in the more real like
practical way and so that's where wendy
gets the up the needle and thread and so
is the uh shadow back shadow black
right and so but it's also warning like
you know because in that i think that
movie they left the pain out of it but i
mean in the play there's some pain
associated with sewing that back onto
peter pan's foot and i think that's also
an important thing to think about that
you don't necessarily have to understand
it explicitly to to participate in the
story to its fullest at all and
sometimes you can actually you can
actually make it a little bit like
you're instead of being in the story
anymore you're looking at a little snow
globe you've shaken up so you do give up
something when you try to break down the
story too yeah definitely because the
story will have more than just the
analysis right that you give of it but
if you're aware of that then you can be
careful uh when you're when you're doing
interpretation
so yeah good advice neil it's good stuff
i just did it i did it guys the best
answer you've given so far all right so
so greg garcia says hi jonathan the
phrase it was meant to be is becoming
increasingly rare technology allows near
infinite potential to be realized and
modern people see almost all aspects of
their lives as contingent from the
marriage to their friendships
communities their their jobs the paradox
of choice exist even for toothpaste and
i was wondering what you thought of the
phrase it was meant to be
for instance do you think you were meant
to start a youtube channel
i like this question yeah it's a really
good question
uh
so no i do think that there is
there is a sense in which some things
are meant to be
um
[Music]
and and i think that you could say like
in some ways like what's meant to be is
that we all
become are joined to christ like who be
that we that we that we that is what
it's meant to be so ultimately that's
what it would be like we're all called
to theosis that's what's meant to be for
us to become god uh through
participation uh but then lower at lower
levels and that can appear
in different ways and so i but i do
believe that what's meant to be will
always be directed
towards that ultimate goal and so even
if it's negative like sometimes there is
suffering sometimes there's there's
danger there could be death there can be
disease
but that ultimately to perceive it as
meant to be
should be in the manner in which it
leads us towards a higher good um and so
i do feel like
like
i do feel like for example that
i have some kind of a mission like i
guess is the best way to say it and i
and in some ways i've
most my brother and i
have felt this for a very long time like
you know for
20 something years
uh but we were just
in it but also just biding our time and
just doing the things that god put in
front of us
uh to the moment when the opportunity to
kind of
come out and start to do to do what we
thought we were supposed to do
didn't i don't see it as being a youtube
channel i see it really more as
participating in a
participating in the re-enchantment of
the world is something that honestly i
felt like
for 20 years i felt like i was gonna
somehow have a little at least a little
participation
in in moving that along and so when i
saw it glimmer in front of me it was not
difficult for me to recognize
to recognize it and to to move towards
it um i don't know what about you what
do you think about
about do you feel like some things are
meant to be like that yeah they always
see it as meant to be in your your own
story
yeah yeah i think so but not everything
i mean you can be malignantly optimistic
about these types of things too and you
know reframe your life up
some people are deluded and that's why
i'm careful because some people are
definitely deluded in like
in their like they're meant to be like
oh yes well god wanted us to be divorced
like that was yeah right right and so
but i mean in in general in culture it
was meant to be i mean that's like the
back end of the fact that
um that there's there's a
way the world has been ordained to be
like so when we haven't someone's having
a moral argument they're saying well i
think it ought to be this way and
someone else saying i think it ought to
be this way
there's a credential at the bottom of
that the credential is that the universe
was
ordained and ordered a certain way and
so that that perspective uh
is becoming more and more rare so that
it would make sense that also the other
side of things it was meant to be would
be more rare i was i was trying this out
on people last night too because i think
there's a secret newer problem that you
can see with twitter is that all
assessments of what is of quality like
the fact that something is good or bad
is really becoming
something that people don't believe
exist outside of whatever the public
impression is of it so
you know the financial space is becoming
a space to be manipulated by perception
only not the actual value of the product
anymore and i think this is a breakdown
that's happening on a very
like the very bottom level of reality so
i think that's a problem too so
that's the whole point when you're
talking about re-enchantment is to bring
back the idea that that you're part of
the story what you see out the window
isn't an arbitrary series of events that
has occurred and you've somehow
accidentally appeared in the middle of
them but it's it's a style of
storytelling that puts you as part of
the story as part of the music
that your life matters and and what's
going on has has a context that actually
matters so um
i think that's important that's one of
the the necessary things about
re-enchantment because it's the answer
to nihilism
and just this despondency people have
because nothing's meant to be and
nothing ought to be one way or another
except for whatever the public can argue
out
and control in their perception
all right so matthew f says what is the
symbolism of balding oh he's saying that
because i'm here
no
i started balding with a lot because of
kobe i just couldn't grow a beard so i
just started i started pulling it out
clumps all right
so
so it's it this is actually it's a good
question to help you understand how
symbolism can sometimes be surprising is
that sometimes i think that sometimes
symbolism
can can represent things that are even
opposite to each other
uh but they're framed by a
a category and so
so balding is definitely like losing
your extensions right losing the man in
which you kind of reach out into the
world and so it can be an image
of it can be an image of concentration
so i think a good example of that that's
interesting is for example in the story
of elijah and elisha i knew you were
going there yeah well i think in that
she bear the she bear i think in that
story there's a whole play about the
idea of like hairy garments and garments
of skin and so
so it's the end of a world
and elisha gets taken up
and he leaves he he like drops his hairy
garments to elisha but elijah is also
bald as like a new beginning as if right
like he's also kind of lost
the the fruits of the old world or
something like that and so and you can
see it like the idea of the hammer that
floats up to the top of the water like
there are different images of that are
kind of
what seems to be wanting to show that
but also there's a play so it's like
he's bald but then he calls the she-bear
that seems to be related directly to
receiving also the garments of skin from
from from elijah so there's like this
he has a relationship with animality
uh it's not totally clear to me but i
think that that's where you can kind of
see how there's a play once you
sometimes once you read you can see the
themes like there's definitely a theme
about animality and hair baldness all of
these things are playing together in the
story of elijah and elisha um so i
thought you have that take there's also
this okay so like we'll just take
greying hair first example yeah so the
idea that you know the highest mountains
have the are topped with white snow most
of the year and so that's one of the
symbolism of the grain but also i think
that balding is actually a positive
symbol yeah um for people in the same
sense that um you know over time like
the idea that over time you're moving up
to the mountain now it's a snow-covered
peak well there's the same notion with
going bald in the sense that at the
higher up the mountain you go the
vegetation stops yeah so it's like an
ascent
into it's like a it's like a over time
you're growing in wisdom and gaining
perspective that's great that's a really
good interpretation you're welcome yeah
they're better than the other one event
should be well i should have you on more
often no no no no no no never do no this
is not what people want
watch watch this q a have like three
times as many views as the other ones
all right so emanuel montiel says hi
jonathan the icons that show the spirit
coming down annunciation of pentecost
seem to be similar to egyptian aten
iconography
aten was represented as an orb above
with life-giving rays coming down on his
creation and had no material body like
the one like the other egyptian gods is
there any symbolic significance behind
this
i think there is i think there is a
relationship between
aten but also uh um ahura mazda the
manner in which ahura mazda was
represented and aten as this globe with
wings sometimes
uh as being the idea of god beyond
manifestation and that is honestly
that's the way we represent god at the
top of icons as a as a circular glory
sometimes a circular glory with just a
hand coming out sometimes just a
circular glory sometimes like a circular
gory which is moved moving towards
darkness so has light on the outside and
darkness on the inside uh but i honestly
you're i i totally agree with you i
think that it has to do
with the the manner in which other
ancient worlds have represented a
monotheistic god uh and so
it's also a good example for people who
think that monotheism is just
it's just when one place in the world it
it actually has instantiations that that
were there
in other cultures or in other places
uh sean's about to create a rift in the
sacred timeline
read it you'll see sean what is the
symbolism of the work you are doing
talking about symbolism
yeah
uh
no i i but i mentioned this before
actually i mentioned this before it it's
that
there it's it's actually quite it's not
a
it's not a simple good is is to say to
say it is that when you explain
symbolism
you are
it you could see it as a crutch maybe
sometimes or maybe you're hoping it's
going to be like a uh like a
what is it you call it like a
ekg or whatever when you you you yeah
jumpstart someone with like a [ __ ] so
you're basically jump starting someone
with a electric current that in normal
times you would kill them by using it
right right and so there i think that
it's a it's a dangerous thing to do
because on the one hand if you when you
explain something
you can limit it and you can also
denature it but
when we come to like the end where thing
nobody sees meaning anymore it can also
act as
as a as a as a crotch for a little while
and also as a kind of restarting
mechanism and that is what we hope at
least that it will be doing but we
like i know matsuri for many years he he
asked himself whether or not
he should talk about that because he
felt like it could
become
it could actually be like explaining
symbolism away it may be a good way to
to to to say that so but as you see i i
mean we've taken our we made our
decision and we do believe that in the
end it is right now better to explain
like my my take is it's like i'll
explain civilism and tell you to go to
church it's like because
it doesn't what i'm saying doesn't is
not does not reduce the meaning that's
not the totality of what it is it is
about experience and about participation
and hopefully this explanation will at
least help you dimly see why it is you
should participate yeah no i don't think
it's i think it's actually there's a
awesome opportunity in the moment we're
in in the sense that these things were
more implicitly understood for a very
long time and we kind of watched them
get squashed out by this modern uh way
of thinking and the modern way of seeing
but it didn't get so far out of sight
that it was totally lost so now what i
think what's happening is we're going to
have both things at the same time
that's an interesting idea so like the
new jerusalem kind of thing yeah it's
going to actually be more it's going to
be more established because not only
will it return because it's a more
satisfying meaningful way of looking at
the world a more uh embodied way of
looking at the world uh it's satisfying
more satisfying in every direction i
feel like but at the same time we're
also going to have the structural
understanding to back it up and protect
it into the future
um so i think right now as a storyteller
it's an incredible time to be alive i'm
excited all right no i think you're
you've definitely convinced me i think
you're you're you when you were talking
and saying that we have both like i
really did see the difference between
the innocence in the garden
and a fall and then finally the garden
with the city you know yeah okay so we
will so we'll both have
you know the the the technical
understanding or the you know the manner
which explain it but also the intuition
the natural patterns and the
architectural patterns at the same time
man that's good good stuff
all right i'm going to stop
i'm going to stop complimenting you
because i just have to compliment you
after everything no i just compliment
him the whole time before we get become
here so he'll let me on
he's like oh this guy is trustworthy he
seems to really understand it
all right so alex couch says what is the
symbolism of the true cross of christ
being broken into pieces and given to
people around the world i felt i feel
like it should have been kept intact and
preserved
um i actually really like the idea
because the cross is itself that
extension you know it's like it's an
extension from the center to the edges
and so i think the i like the idea that
the cross was actually pieces of the
cross are sent out to kind of cover all
of all of the world um yeah so it
doesn't bother me at all
um all right so here we go
so someone asked are you a gnostic and
the answer is no
i am a christian
but i mean yeah
that's the best answer
all right so annie crawford says i was
listening to the episode on agri-gore's
while also reading rousseau it strikes
me that his concept of the general real
will which is an emergent reality may be
a form of agrigore for so the general
will
of those who come together in social
contract is the true sovereign of the
state however
what exactly general will is ambiguous
and it seems to serve nothing higher
than itself yet this principle governs
much democratic political theory and
rejecting monarchy have western
democracies really
been creating and serving wars
is this why democracy is always a
precursor to tyranny yes i do believe
that i do think that the democracy
is a problem in the sense that
it's often
this is the best way to say it it can
often be just secretly guided
in the sense that
you think that it's all these people
that want something but it's because
they're under the influence of something
else that's why they want it and so
what happens is in the democracy that
influence will separate itself and so
there'll be different influences and so
people will embody like a particular
aspect of the world and will will will
be under its influence and then we'll
want will vote for that that they will
want that um
and so so i think that
that's why ultimately it that ultimately
leads to kind of a
impossible opposition that cannot be
resolved or it leads to an actual
fragmentation and breakdown of the wills
into like all these different parties
that are fighting amongst each other uh
ultimately leading again to uh
to a tyranny so so i think you've got a
good a good uh grasp on that have you
ever read that hideous strength by c.s
lewis yeah yeah because i mean there's
something something with the
conversation about edgar gore's i think
you have in that story and i guess it's
a little bit of a spoiler so cover your
ears if you haven't read yet but they
create this machine that's supposed to
bring back this this spirit that they
love from the past as opposed to guide
them but that's not what occupies the
machine right so there's a there's
something about this discussion of error
is i kind of feel like yeah there are
certain maybe there's certain spirits
out there that are happy for you to
think that you invented it so now it can
control you yeah exactly because i just
don't see
i don't i don't see things really
manifesting that way that there really
is something that can exist
in the heavens that came just bottom up
yeah so yeah exactly all right you're
right okay so can i do right here go for
it austin rush well i'm to give austin
rush a uh you know a question here
because they complimented me
um no would you uh they would love to
see something about the story um
symbolism in the story of gideon and
i've always been fascinated with the
story too i've always thought it's been
a really uh it's a real beautiful scene
too and a really um interesting scene so
do you ever do anything on gideon or i
don't think i have i answer many
questions no not most people i know i
don't think many people have asked
questions about disturbing so maybe i
could do that i could do a video
but i would have to think about it
because it's a it's a complex story
there's a lot of stuff going on with the
little lantern reveal at the end yeah
yeah
yeah the trickery that if trickery
that's related to light you know for
sure like the the the
the fleece um has been is an image that
a lot of the church fathers use
uh but and i'd have to think about it uh
more and maybe we could do that
all right
okay so nick
eggensberger says hey jonathan seeing as
both the left and the right hand are
important symbols i was wondering what
the symbolism of the left-handed person
would be
i'm sorry if you have spoken on this
before i was not able to find any
concrete answer to that uh and so
you know in most i think in most
traditional societies the left-handed
person
would have been guided towards using
their right hand
they would have been rectified
it's a direct way of saying it and so
the thing about being left-handed is
that you are in a way i'm left-handed by
the way so really yes so i can say this
that's why i was killing you in arm
wrestling last night so so so the the
left-handed person will appear as an
exception and as a marginal person and
will
be
awkward
will be more awkward because the world
is made for right-handed per people uh
so for example like when i rolls of the
world are made for right-handed people
so it's like when i write you know i
smear my
hand
because i'm writing over the the text
that i'm writing yeah so that's a little
example but it's like when i'm driving a
car
i always like if i'm drinking something
i have to like put the drink in my other
hand because i can't drink with my right
hand you can't even do that while i'm
driving that's messing up
so much like more than that was in the
cup it was magical it's great uh so i
think that that i think that that's what
will happen and so the the left-handed
person will appear as more awkward but i
do think that there's also
another possibility which is that
the world will
naturally rectify even if like so so
a good way to seeing it is that like for
we don't live in a world where they
force let's say left-handed people to
write with their right hand anymore but
the world naturally rectifies us it just
kind of happens and so because of that
there's a man in which sometimes the
left-handed person also has more scope
than the right-handed person because i
end up being ambidextrous much more than
a right-handed person would be so
there's a disadvantage but that
disadvantage can be turned into an
advantage uh just like you could say
the same way in which a marginal person
themselves can have more flexibility
let's say
and so i think that that's the way that
i see it well you see this too in a real
practical example um in two different
sports one's golf and one's baseball in
golf it's only like four percent of the
golfers are left-handed they're
under-represented because golf clubs are
expensive most of the golf clubs in the
world are right-handed and as a
left-handed person you're less likely to
have easy access to clubs right so but
then a sport like baseball um you can
see which is more like a head-to-head
combat left-handers are far more
over-represented because for a
right-handed pitcher it's harder to
throw to a left-hander and people are
face less left-handed picture pitchers
on the way up so
it becomes awkward to hit against the
left-hander so there is like there is
like a surprise to being left-handed
like when it comes to combat is that you
know you're used to training against
right-handers right-handers a
left-hander who might not even be at
your skill level can just totally catch
you off guard so there's something about
a surprise in the left-handed uh-ness
but also like most things like it kind
of shows us things we would take for
granted if it didn't exist either just
you know aspects of the world yeah but i
remember seeing that when i was doing
fencing when i was younger oh
we i mean i could the same i could beat
people that were clearly much better
than yeah but i was always fighting
against right-handers so i had trained
that way right right they they would
rarely fight against left-handers and so
they were struggling to kind of figure
out how to get in there
um yeah
who wants to see a jonathan pajot
fencing video oh yeah let's get one of
those up here all right so joshua
foreman says mrs harris goes to paris is
a modern take on older stories and the
much better movie mrs harris which are
plays on the story of cinderella
i don't think i know what you're talking
about here since you've not covered
cinderella in full to my knowledge what
is the basic symbol the basic symbolism
of the story of cinderella from the
perspective of the woman
i ask from the woman's perspective
because of these modern takes but also
because
as a symbol of the bride of christ
cinderella seems pertinent to our
current situation as loved lovers of a
true savior
so
i don't know i don't even know what that
is miss goes to mrs harris goes to paris
but the cinderella is an image of
it's it's an image of the the the
the gold hidden in the fish right it's
the idea of beauty hidden in ashes
and it's the idea that
you have to be attentive and that
there's something about
femininity which is also in a way hidden
in the lowest in the lowest and if you
uh if you have the right attention
then you will find that secretly hidden
in
these low places are
the can be the highest thing or the most
beautiful thing and so
i think that that's what it's about it's
about hidden beauty and so that's why
that's why she is made beautiful by her
fairy you know fairy godmother
and that's why you know the prince
doesn't know her he he he sees her
beauty but then he has to search for her
and he has to search the land and that's
why it also has to do with the shoe
because it has to do with the bottom of
reality it has to do with like finding
finding the precious things in in hidden
darkness
yeah that's why it's the shoe as well
and so it's so also why whether
cinderella means ashes and so so it's
cinder so she because she she lies in
the ash and so she she's herself uh
let's say related to the ash so you can
think of it like almost like an
alchemical process too like the idea of
of transforming the the the ash into
into gold let's say well i think too is
just as a storyteller it's a very
winning pattern i mean it engages people
um
and it gets used inappropriately
sometimes because of that like you know
um but a good example of that is like
harry potter living under his these you
know distant relative staircase and that
secretly he's there's something royal
about him there's a sense of royalty to
him he's destined for something and that
cinderella the same kind of thing and
you can kind of imagine that there's a
relatability for uh people who feel just
part of the herd out there and unseen
that there there might be something
about them and you see it in the story
of christ christ hiding in the cave with
the animals in the lowest place in the
manger is another version what's the
ultimate version in fact of that notion
of the hidden the hidden good um
and so uh so yeah
hidden in the cinders hidden this is a
bella
so ken larry says i've been looking into
bridging between evolutionary theory and
christianity these strike me as
analogous understandings of humanity in
relation to the transcendent from the
perspective of rational
particularization and spiritual
revelation religio of particulars
respectively both frames depend on a
progressive revelation discovery of
heaven to earth chaos and order etc i'm
wondering how you might approach this
bridging
as the frames you have communicated are
only
ones i see this bridge
developing upon
um and so i think it's an i think it's
an it's a possible interesting venture i
would be careful
um
how can i say this it's like i say this
i think i said it's often i think
i like the notion of natural selection i
think that's wonderful because it it
actually reveals the man in which being
persists
and it also you know
it reveals the teleological aspect of
reality how things are moving towards
towards purpose and that this frames
everything but i definitely do not like
evolution as a sorry evolution as a
story
as a and so i would i would just be
careful to uh evolution in the sense of
the way they historically describe all
this like procession of of beings you
know and i find that just not i just
find it's not a very good um it's not a
very good story so that's what i would
be careful of like i i think that
natural selection and the process that
have been uncovered about that can be
extremely useful for the religious
person state
but but that the story
if you're if you go too much into the
story part of it it will the genesis
story is a much better description of
reality than that description than the
description that the evolutionary
biologists give us of uh
of the origin of things let's say does
that make sense oh yeah totally the
gospel of john even kind of takes it
you know to a
a more even more more relatable level
because that the truth and everything
that's being exposed ends up being
a person in christ the word the logos
so i think yeah i like your answers
that's why i watch these things i'm
watching it very close this week
so joshua foreman says if the shape of
all creation
is a pyramid triangle all pointing up to
the headstone which is christ the
incarnation of god what is the shape of
heaven
and so
there are different ways to represent it
and also like by the way there are also
different ways to represent uh creation
you know the pyramid is one way that is
very useful and so you could you could
understand creation uh you could
actually understand it if you saw it at
the mountain going like this you could
also understand um
heaven as a as a triangle pointing
towards the
towards the the summit of the mountain
that is one way of understanding it you
can understand it as a
as just the hierarchy itself right so
that is even even on the mountain you
could understand that heaven
is the ascent itself it's the vertical
relationship of beings that is what
heaven is uh whereas earth is the
horizontal relationship of being so
at any level of reality you could
understand that the that the vertical
causation is heaven
wherever you are and that the horizontal
causation is earth so all the elements
of something
that's earth and the man in which those
elements come together and jump into
a
a name or an identity that is something
like going into heaven or you know the
influence of heaven the gift of heaven
all these ways that the bible talks
about it you know um and so i think that
that's probably the best way to to
understand it there are different ways
to represent it but
it's better to understand it you know
because
all right so
all right okay we go right ross bird
says hi jonathan what do you make of the
parable of the unjust steward in luke
16.
i'm not going to answer ross because i
think i've answered this a few times but
i don't totally understand this and and
it's it's funny because well let me read
it let me read it maybe people can help
the steward is getting fired so he goes
to the masters debtors he cancels a
portion of their debts in the end the
master commands the steward and says and
jesus says i tell you make friends for
yourself by means of unrighteous wealth
so that it fails so when it fails they
may receive you
into the eternal dwellings and so
it is a very very mysterious
description but i think
it i think it has something to do
it has something to do with with
the fact that
reality lays itself out in a pattern
despite our will even like despite our
our intentions you could say that these
things are going to happen
and so that is like the best intuition
about i have i don't know neil have you
thought about this story i have yeah
actually we'll go for it wow okay well
no there's something
part of the mystery of some of the
parables and the sermon on the mount is
that
uh you know christ is doing something i
don't i don't know if you've seen it
anywhere else in the world at that point
is that
there's there's a way i guess the best
analogy for it is the the night sky
reflecting in the ocean is that there's
a reflection of the heavens above that's
here
and then there's the way the heavens
actually are so there's an economy
of the reflection where people can
mistakenly
think they're climbing
okay so like you know the beatitudes are
like blessed are the poor in spirit
blessed are the meek for they shall
inherit and it's talking about all these
things that according to this this
economy in this temporal lifetime
um
they sound like you're at the bottom but
if you recognize that what he's exposing
that part of what we're what we're doing
here is seeing a reflection of the
heavens that what the first shall be
last and the last shall be first is that
that the ones at the bottom are actually
you know of the highest economy for
heaven so okay so getting into this it's
it's another it's like a double leafy
love double inversion so there's a
double inversion here
is that you have this it's like you know
you can't love god and mammon at the
same time but then he's still like he's
showing you ways
that seem like a trick within the system
that it can actually be used to create
something like even that can be used to
point to something eternal
yeah but
in this case what what why like make
friends
by means of unrighteous wealth
that means about like meaning but he's
basically he's releasing debt
yeah he's releasing debt for his master
so maybe
so maybe it could be something like
that we also kind of participate in the
they give forgiveness in some ways like
of course somehow that like if we act on
behalf of others
like we forgive on behalf of others even
that somehow this is going to
surprisingly
like
yeah no right but that's like so you're
connecting it back when you're
connecting it back to is also this idea
whatever you uh bind on earth will be
bound in heaven whatever you forgive on
earth will be forgiven heaven so i see
that in the pattern too
um but it you know it's a surprise in
the sense that like there's
if you don't want your debts to be held
against you you forgive others their
debts and so it seems to be
participating that but in like a
surprising way because there's almost
something sneaky about it there is
definitely something yeah you know but i
mean
that is all
i mean that's a pattern that happens
with the bible there is like the the
holy trick
and it seems to be participating in part
of that for me
all right well i'm gonna keep thinking
about it one day
i'll try to give like a very most the
most concise thing i can give but that's
my thought on it which is good it's good
that's all right hey dougie all right
i'm sorry saying hi to people all right
all right what we got any other
questions in there
all right so this next question is very
odd
so girl next door says hello i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the two women in
revelation i know you have mentioned the
harlot briefly in previous talks but
hope you can do an episode addressing
them or at the very least share some
thoughts in the q a so
yeah so i have talked about the harlot
more like the the [ __ ] of babylon more
um
and and i think definitely they are they
are represented as somehow being the
opposite of each other so the difference
between
a mother who has a child and that that
mother is gets she gets raised up right
she gets taken up to the top of the
mountain i think it is or raised up
towards heaven and then the harlot she
is you know she's mixture she's chaos
she's all these things and so she gets
eaten by the by the beast so i think
that that's probably the best way to to
to to understand it and that and so the
idea would be that
in the moment of the harlot and the bees
like in the moment where this
thing below is playing itself out in
terms of tyranny and chaos and all of
that that the the purposeful life the
the woman with the child the one with
the seed
it gets taken taken up
very much kind of like we talked about
before in terms of elijah
uh or in terms even of christ going up
you know and so that the world will will
kind of collapse so it seems like
there's a sense in which that's what's
going on the woman with the child gets
taken up and is protected
hidden
while while the world is kind of going
into chaos and tyranny uh and then
there'll be like a return let's say in
order to start the world against
something like that
um anyway so that's my understanding of
that
all right we're almost done here
so
i'm dominic eliot says shalom brother
maximus christ is with us how do you see
the ten plagues relating with the
creation of the world as with the the
the wedding of kana
so for sure the the ten plays are an
undoing of creation clearly they're an
undoing of creation and they they
actually scale all of creation they
start with water and then they move up
to dust uh and then they then they move
up to to to the world to the animals
and they keep going up and then they
they affect man directly with the boils
and then they keep going up into the
heavens with hail and and and so water
and fire falling together at the same
time
and then you have uh
predators coming from above these
locusts that come down to destroy the
world and finally you have
darkness so it's really is like an
undoing of creation which starts below
and just goes all the way up into that
into the heavens um but it also is in
many ways a reverse
of what's going to happen as they leave
egypt it's super crazy because
so if you look at the pattern you can
see like the fire and water mixed
together and that's what's bringing
death but when the egyptian when the
israelites leave you have fire and water
appearing as two distinct columns of
reality one guiding during the day one
gutting during the night when they get
to the to the sea
the plagues there's an east wind that
comes and blows the locusts into the
world and then when you get to the to
the sea there's also a wind which blows
open the the sea in order to create the
world so in the the plagues you see like
the wind or the spirit of god are the
heavens acting like a predator which
comes down to devour and then you see
again the heaven and the spirit of god
acting
like a
like a wind which reveals the world
again for a new beginning
but the most mysterious
is of course
that this leads to two things
it leads to two taking of the firstborn
the first is something like the end of a
world where god removes the seed from
the world
removes the firstborn
and that's the end of their world
but then there's also the voluntary
sacrifice of the firstborn because if
you read the text it immediately goes
into telling the israelites that they
also have to sacrifice their firstborn
but that they are offered a redemption
so they can redeem their firstborn with
the sacrifice with a willing sacrifice
of an of a pure animal but it's like
the willing sacrifice
is what begins the world
the accidental or like inevitable
taking away of the seed is what so it's
like if you don't sacrifice willingly
you're it's going to get taken from you
it's go you're going to die and you're
going to lose the things that you find
precious but if you purposefully
sacrifice
then they will be redeemed
you will like if you give up things they
will in a way be given back to you in in
a very strange and mysterious way and
that's actually like the secret of how a
world begins is the is the willingness
to give up towards a higher purpose and
then getting the world in exchange and
so
and so that's why i said that it's
related to the wedding of kana because
in the wedding of kana it starts with
christ changing the water into wine
and then but when when when when the
mother of god asks christ to solve that
problem what does he say he says
woman it is not my time yet and it's
like what this seems like the craziest
thing but he's saying he knows that if
you change the water into wine the
firstborn will die
he knows that
and so but he also knows that it's him
he also knows that he has to give
himself up as the firstborn as the
sacrifice as all of those things coming
together to restart the world um and
that's what's being played out in that
story it's wild it is it is the final
version of the plagues of egypt um
nice work hot shot that's good
i love that stuff well too you know i
mean there's even there's
uh there's a little epilogue to that in
the sense that what happens at that
wedding feast is that the normal pattern
of love and relationship in marriage is
that
over time the quality of the wine
declines right but you know when christ
inhabits
uh this relationship that you know the
best is yet to come yeah but it's also
ecstasy is ahead yes and it's a mystery
about
about how the end becomes the beginning
and how and and it's a mystery because
what what christ does in the sacrifice
when christ dies on the cross
he is both
he's
he is both the firstborn of the
egyptians being taken and the redemption
and the firstborn being given
acting as the redemption of the
firstborn at the same time so it's like
he it's like crazy like that jesus's
story just drives you crazy it's like
it's as if that the the what happened in
exodus is being condensed into one thing
both sides are appearing at the same
time it's like when we say that jesus is
both goats right he's he's both the the
the he's both the sacrifice of atonement
and the scapegoat it's like it's all of
that is coming together in the cross and
i think that for the story of exodus
christ is is both
the the the child of the egyptians being
taken up
and the redemption sacrifice
willing redemption sacrifice given
instead of all the firstborn and it's
like it just shatters you when you think
about it yeah it's crazy
all right
all right here we go i think we're
almost done that's the end that's the
end all right so chandler turner i
shouldn't end with that question because
man i don't know if i can do another one
all right chancellor good evening
jonathan in one of your recent
conversations you said you've been
reading parts of
meditations of the tarot yes my question
is do you have any insight into le pazu
do you want me to do a french accent oh
please i feel that this image of the
upside down man is relevant not only to
my life but to a broader moment so i
have to know i haven't gotten there so i
have to i will when i read that part i
might like maybe after i'm finished
reading it i might do
i might do like one video on on the the
nuggets that i got from that book maybe
we'll see we'll decide once we finish
reading it the drew mcmahon asks can you
talk about the story of sodom and
gomorrah
was the major sin in hospitality
something else why is homosexuality such
a big focus thank you and so i will
explain that to you
i will explain to you very clearly
that it's fractal
lack of hospitality
it's fractal abuse of hospitality and so
there's a type
so there's a type of bodily interaction
with others which is proper hospitality
which brings about life
and there is a type of bodily
interaction
which is
coming in from the back door which is in
hospitality which is an abuse of
hospitality and so there's a direct
relationship between the abuse of
hospitality which is done at a social
level and the abuse of hospitality which
is being threatened at a personal level
and so
hopefully
that will settle that question for good
because
so it's not about homosexuality at all
it's about
abuse of hospitality but it does have
sexual connotation has more to do with
with sodomy than with
homosexuality as a general character as
a as a general characteristic like
let's say and so
the real simple sense there's like the
food plays a major part in the story and
right very beginning with the
hospitality in the sense that you know
um abraham sees this he wants to feed
the angels yeah but also needs his
people but not just that he he wants he
has proper hospitality towards the
angels and that will give
that will bring what brings a child yeah
it will bring a proper relationship of
hospitality between abraham and sarah so
there's a social hospitality which is
reflected in a sexual hospitality and
then when they get to sodom and gomorrah
there's the same thing a social
hospitality which is threatening a
sexual inhospitality right well i mean
so there but there's so it could be too
like it could be it doesn't oh it's not
just it's just his sodomy it could be
rape as well rape is also an abuse of
hospitality so there are different ways
to to manifest sexually the abuse of
hospitality which leads to death but
that is definitely one of them
it's not arbitrary where we use that
word to talk about
and and in the ancient world sodomy was
a general word to talk about
let's say abuses of hospitality in the
sexual sphere where it wasn't a proper
relationship
well yeah the appetites were leading the
action as opposed to let's say legacy
yeah there you go that's a good way to
think about it so uh so yeah that was
just such a wonderful question to end on
yeah of course they always do that to
you i feel like that's like i who picks
your questions or lets lisa sort through
them she just likes to drop those kind
at the end all right so all right so
everybody thanks for your uh thanks for
your time
and uh and uh so i hope you enjoyed our
special q a with neil and so we're going
to hang out still in florida for a few
days if you want to hear more about like
the the whole winning kind of thing and
the crossing of the red sea i am
recording this uh exodus seminar with
jordan peterson which should go up
on the daily wire i guess uh
in the next few months so uh thanks
everybody
and uh yeah we'll see you soon
bye-bye two million all you